[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend wer in all dem leid und
elend des ukraine krieges etwas
entdecken wollte was zuversicht geben
konnte verwies in den letzten wochen
gerne auf den schulterschluss des
westens bisher jedenfalls machte das die
stärke europas und der nato aus die
große einigkeit im ziel den aggressor zu
stoppen doch nun beginnt es wieder zu
bröseln und zu bröckeln
wie der deutsche wirtschaftsminister
herr beck mit blick auf den gerade
laufenden eu gipfel in brüssel
formulierte dort geht es heute abend um
das öl embargo gegen russland und nicht
nur um ganz viktor orban stellt für
seine zustimmung bedingungen zum blog
berichtet
gewohnt selbstbewusst ungarns
ministerpräsident viktor orban zeigt
sich zu beginn des gipfels wie man es
von ihm kennt er will das sechste
sanktionspaket der eu gegen russland mit
tragen aber nur wenn die
energieversorgung seines landes
sichergestellt ist dass öl embargo ist
ihm bislang ein dorn im auge auf seinem
facebook account postete er provokant
brüssel die schlacht beginnt
energie ist ein sehr ernstes thema das
ist kein kinderspiel
das heißt erst brauchen wir lösungen
dann die sanktionen
denn ungarn bekommt sein rohöl zu 65
prozent aus russland dieses öl fließt
vollständig über die druschba pipeline
nach ungarn dass es daher wieder einmal
schwierig werden würde in der eu mit
einer stimme zu sprechen zeichnete sich
schon vor dem gipfel ab so hoffnungsvoll
wie bundeskanzler olaf scholz klang
daher auch nicht alle man soll nie einen
tag vor dem abend loben aber alles was
ich wahrnehme es dass es wirklich
gespräche gibt die mit dem willen zu
einer verständigung geführt werden und
das ist gut es gibt verschiedene
lösungsvorschläge auf dem tisch
aber wir sind diesen schritt nämlich
dass wir eine gemeinsame position
beziehen können den haben wir noch nicht
erreicht ein kompromissvorschlag für das
öl-embargo sieht vor dass öl das auf dem
seeweg transportiert wird immerhin rund
zwei drittel soll in sanktionspaket
aufgenommen werden das restliche drittel
das über die pipeline druschba fließt
soll weiterhin nach ungarn kommen doch
das allein reicht aber bislang noch
nicht
wir brauchen eine garantie im falle
eines unfalls mit der pipeline von
russland durch die ukraine müssen wir
das recht bekommen russisches öl auf
anderem wege zu erhalten wenn wir das
bekommen ist es gut
doch orban hängt an seine forderungen
noch ein großes preisschild 550
millionen euro will ungarn offenbar für
die umstellung auf nicht russisches öl
weiteres geld für eine alternative
pipeline diese ausnahmen wiederum ärgern
die niederlande die sich selbst teureres
öl bei arabischen staaten auf dem seeweg
holen müssen der ukrainische präsident
sie lenski auf dem brüsseler gipfel
zugeschaltet man am abend deswegen zur
einigkeit die eu müsse ihre
streitigkeiten beenden und auch andere
warnen sich in zu vielen details zu
verlieren
es wird uns mehr kosten aber es ist nur
geld die ukraine zahlen mit ihrem leben
wenn jedes europäische land nur noch an
sich selbst denkt bewegen wir uns
niemals vorwärts und so diskutieren die
staats und regierungschefs auf diesem
gipfel eben nicht nur über das geld
sondern auch wieder über gemeinsame
europäische werte
ja und in brüssel beobachtet eine klinik
die verhandlungen jetzt hören wir zwar
vom willen zur verständigung aber wie
ist der aktuelle verlauf zeichnet sich
jetzt ein tragfähiger kompromiss ab die
27 staats und regierungschefs chefin
haben sich jetzt zum abendessen zurück
gezogen sind aber mit den verhandlungen
über das 6 über das sechste
sanktionspaket noch nicht fertig sie
reden beim abendessen weiter das klingt
also eher nach verhaken es gilt auch
nicht wirklich als wahrscheinlich dass
die chefs hier in brüssel den durchbruch
erzielen dafür sind die details von
pipelines und raffinerien rüstungen zu
technisch
wir hören auch dass viktor orban seinen
widerstand gegen das paket noch nicht
aufgegeben hat es kann also auch gut
sein dass sich die verhandlungen noch in
die nächste woche schleppen und am ende
das paket von den eu botschafter
beschlossen werden muss und das heißt
dann auch eine dass es ein vollständiges
öl-embargo vermutlichen gar keinen fall
geben wird oder nein ein vollständiges
öl embargo ist bereits vom tisch es ist
wohl beschlossene sache dass die
pipeline an der zum beispiel ungarn und
die slowakei und tschechien hängen dass
die von dem embargo ausgenommen wird
aber immerhin trifft ist dann immer noch
zwei drittel des russischen rubels das
eben per schiff nach europa geschafft
wird aber auch hier muss man sagen das
würde putin schon treffen aber die
umstände unter denen dieses paket zu
stande kommt die stimmen einen doch ein
bisschen bedenklich da trauen sich die
europäischen mitgliedsstaaten
gegenseitig nicht über den weg so haben
die niederlande heute verlangt dass die
deutschen eine schriftliche erklärung
abgeben dass sie auf jeden fall zum
jahresende kein öl mehr aus der druschba
pipeline entnehmen würden und ungarn
wiederum fordert ebenfalls schriftliche
garantien von seinen nachbarn dass es
auf jeden fall hilfe erhalten würde
falls russland die ölpipeline zu drehen
sollte also da ist schon ein ziemliches
hauen und stechen im gang und kein land
hat das gefühl jedes land möchte nicht
zu kurz kommen und das ist schon eine
sehr bedenkliche vorstellung die die
europäer hier abgeben und ich glaube die
hilft nur einem dem mann im kreml latina
putin so ist es wohl ein hauen und
stechen danke an du beobachtest das
weiter danke für den moment auf der
tagesordnung des gipfels steht bis
morgen mittag auch die weitere
finanzielle unterstützung für die
ukraine werde es gehört und die
zusammenarbeit der eu im bereich
sicherheit und verteidigung da ist für
die partner von interesse was letzte
nacht in berlin verabschiedet wurde 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr der s
und das hat sich in europa bis zum
letzten rumgesprochen an vielem mangelt
von helmen bis panzern dieses sogenannte
sondervermögen hatte olaf scholz ende
februar in seiner zeitenwende rede
angekündigt seit gestern abend 23 uhr
ungefähr ist es nur und beschlossene
sache und das ist eine historische
wendung deutschland rüstet auf zu den
reaktionen am tag danach daniel pontzen
es war ein außergewöhnlicher tag heute
im politischen berlin nicht nur wegen
der höhe des sogenannten sondervermögens
mehr noch weil die opposition sich dafür
rühmt ein vorhaben des kanzlers
durchgesetzt zu haben die drei
entscheidenden worte waren gefettet in
der vorlage für die grundgesetzänderung
für die bundeswehr sei das
sondervermögen diese ausschließlichkeit
hatte im ersten entwurf gefehlt es zeigt
auch dass wir es ernst meinen wenn wir
sagen dass wir eine verantwortungsvolle
und konstruktive opposition im deutschen
bundestag sein wollen ich bin dankbar
dass spd und grüne ihre anderen
vorschläge dieses geld zu verwenden
aufgegeben haben und damit war dann auch
der weg frei gemeint hier vor allem
ausgaben für cyber abwehr auch dafür
soll es geld geben aber aus dem normalen
haushalt nicht wie von den grünen
gewünscht aus dem sondervermögen in
einer zeit in der die sicherheit in
europa so herausgefordert ist wie jetzt
wäre es für uns keine option gewesen
daran eine einigung scheitern zu lassen
und deswegen haben wir gemeinsam als
ampel fraktionen einen anderen weg
gefunden die notwendigen investitionen
abzusichern
zufrieden gab sich der urheber des
sondervermögens heute auf der hannover
messe
die deutsche bundeswehr wird gestärkt
werden sie wird in der lage sein ihren
verteidigungsauftrag besser als jemals
zu erfüllen und sie wird ihren beitrag
in der nato leisten können damit wir uns
gegen angriffe von außen jederzeit zur
wehr setzen können
unterstützung seiner eigenen partei
bekommt scholz nur noch deshalb weil
eine seiner zeitenwenden zusagen nicht
gesetzlich verankert wird
jahr für jahr mehr als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts und unserer
verteidigung investieren diese zwei
prozent sein so der eigene fraktionschef
heute eine vollkommen abstruse
kennziffer wir haben uns nie an dieser
kennziffer orientiert sondern wir wollen
fähigkeitslücken schließen
fähigkeitslücken inhalt der bundeswehr
wollen zu einem besseren
beschaffungswesen kommen und kennziffern
deuten ja eben auch an dass sie keine
aussagekraft haben und dann ist da noch
die frage der finanzierung
sondervermögen ist ein sehr hübscher
begriffe sehr hohen schulden und sehr um
konkrete vorstellungen zur tilgung die
soll erst beginnen wenn alles ausgegeben
ist einfach über den daumen teilung
würde man sagen
2028 beginne die tilgung über 30 jahre
von 100 milliarden
beginne konjunktiv und pi mal daumen
arithmetik das dürfte einen schmerzen
der eigentlich nichts wie weg will vom
schuldenmachen egal wie das ganze nun
heißt
und das wo wir vertiefen mit dem
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
stimmen abend nach berlin guten abend
rauschten lindner 100 milliarden
sondervermögen das klingt als könnten
sie jetzt etwas von der hohen kante
nehmen in wahrheit müssen sie aber ja
kredite aufnehmen schulden machen wie
sehr widerstrebt ihnen das als
finanzminister ich habe mir ein mulmiges
gefühl bei den hohen schulden die wir
machen müssen kriegsbedingt und weil die
korona pandemie noch nicht überwunden
ist das habe ich mir nicht abgewöhnt
aber dennoch ist etwas gelungen wir
haben ja eine sicherheitspolitische und
eine ökonomische zeitenwende die
sicherheitspolitische zeitenwende
beantworten wir mit 100 milliarden
investitionen in die bundeswehr aber die
schuldenbremse des grundgesetzes bleibt
gleichzeitig erhalten es ist eine
einmalige ausnahme die im grundgesetz ja
auch vorgegeben wird und damit bekämpfen
wird zugleich die inflation das
wichtigste was wir nämlich tun müssen
ist den staat aus der dauerhaften
verschuldung herauszuführen es handelt
sich doch bei dem sondervermögen jetzt
schon ganz objektiv um einen
schattenhaushalt oder anders das ist ja
dann im grunde schon der zweite nach der
umwidmung von corona krisen krediten für
den klimafonds da wurde ihm ja von ihren
kritikern sogar trickserei vorgeworfen
nochmal wie geht wie sehr geht ihnen das
gegen den strich sie haben sich auf die
fahnen geschrieben solide haushalten zu
wollen und nun können andere sagen das
ist der schulden lindner
nichts kann ja weniger ein
schattenhaushalt sein als etwas was
sogar in die verfassung geschrieben wird
also stärker im scheinwerferkegel der
öffentlichkeit kann es nicht stehen es
ist gelungen ein aufweichen ein
dauerhaftes aufweichen der
schuldenbremse zu verhindern das war
teilweise vorgeschlagen und ich rufe in
erinnerung es hat in den neunziger
jahren mal ein solidaritäts zuschlag
gegeben der eingeführt worden ist nach
dem irak krieg also ich schreibe mir auf
die fahnen schuldenbremse erhalten
steuererhöhungen abgewendet bundeswehr
stärker finanziert in einem tricks und
krisenjahr ist das ein guter beginn die
haushaltskonsolidierung fortzusetzen
aber vermutlich beschleicht sie dann
doch manchmal die sorge dass das alles
nicht richtig hinzukriegen es wir haben
das schon verstanden also ab 23 soll
alles wieder normal sein schuldenbremse
eingehalten werden daran wollen sie ja
dann auch gemessen werden aber ist das
realistisch auch angesichts der
erfahrung von diesem jahr da muss ja
immer wieder neu nach gefüttert werden
wie sich der krieg in der ukraine
entwickelt ist ja nicht vorhersehbar
natürlich haben wir mit unsicherheiten
zu tun aber wir betreiben vorsorge wir
haben jetzt in dieser woche den haushalt
22 im bundestag und ich führe die ersten
gespräche mit den ressortkollegen und
kollegen über den haushalt 23 das ist
kein selbstläufer
die öffentlichen haushalte aus den
schulden heraus zu führen fordert ja
eine andere politik wir haben uns ja
daran gewöhnt schulden zu machen ich
gehe sogar so weit zu sagen dass manche
geradezu süchtig danach sind
subventionen zu zahlen für alles möglich
und das müssen wir uns abgewöhnen gute
wirtschaftspolitik kann nicht mehr
bedeuten alles mögliche mit staatlichem
geld zu fördern das geht jetzt um gute
rahmenbedingungen und wer die inflation
ernst nimmt ich tue das das ist großes
wirtschaftliches risiko der muss jetzt
druck von den preisen nehmen muss die
öffentliche verschuldung reduzieren 2023
ist nämlich die schuldenbremse nicht
verhandelt haben fast acht prozent
inflation die preise ziehen immer mehr
an belasten die menschen jetzt schlägt
der arbeitsminister an heilen wegen der
hohen energiepreise ein klima geld für
niedrige und mittlere einkommen vor was
die sozialverbände eine offenbar ganz
prima idee finden und sie ärgert dass
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe sie haben
ja gerade von sucht gesprochen das
trifft vielleicht herrn heil und sie
haben schon den nächsten streit in der
ampel oder also bei sucht nach
subventionen meinte ich nicht die
entlastung der menschen frau / dpa die
fdp hat schon vor der inflation über
entlastung gesprochen dann werden bei in
der inflation das nur umso dringlicher
vortragen das instrument aber von herrn
heil das müssen wir diskutieren das
passt nicht sehr bürokratisch ein neuer
umverteilungs topf und deshalb ist mein
ganz einfacher vorschlag lassen sie uns
im nächsten jahr eine reform der lohn
und einkommenssteuer machen um die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen zu
entlasten und um die sogenannte kalte
progression in der inflation zu
verhindern also ein einfaches bekanntes
instrument
das klima geld von herrn heil auch nicht
schon
ganz und gar nicht da steht drin dass
für die zukünftigen einnahmen aus der
co2 bepreisung pro kopf eine auszahlung
an die menschen erfolgt herr heil möchte
jetzt allgemeine umverteilung mit
haushaltsmitteln machen und da gibt es
bessere wege der erste weg heißt lohn
und einkommenssteuer reform der zweite
weg heißt grundsicherung anpassen an die
inflation damit bedürftige menschen
nicht unter die räder kommen wo da
jedenfalls haben sie dann sicherlich
innerhalb der ampel koalition noch zu
diskutieren vielen dank für heute abend
christian lindner danke frau schausten
das gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet und schauen jetzt auf das
kriegsgeschehen in der ukraine in den
nachrichten gundula gause im osten der
ukraine dauern die heftigen gefechte
russische truppen haben offenbar das
strategisch wichtige ziele wie er oder
netz gestürmt die stadt ist das letzte
größere gebiet im don was das noch in
ukrainischer hand war
aufnahmen des russischen
staatsfernsehens sollen zeigen dass das
schwer umkämpfte es hier wie router netz
unter russischer kontrolle ist die
ukrainische seite bestätigte den
einmarsch die lage sei sehr schwierig
infrastruktur und zwei drittel der
wohnhäuser zerstört die bundesregierung
hat die schnelle und unbürokratische
aufnahme von verfolgten russinnen und
russen beschlossen
bundesinnenministerium feser erklärte
wie sehr verfahren würden deutlich
beschleunigt die regelung gelte für
russischen journalisten sowie für andere
gefährdete personen wie kreml-kritiker
die wegen ihres einsatzes gegen die
ukraine krieg bedroht seien in nepal
haben rettungskräfte das wrack eines
seit gestern vermissten flugzeugs
gefunden 21 der insgesamt 22 insassen
wurden bislang tot geborgen an bord
waren auch zwei reisende aus deutschland
die unglücksstelle liegt auf rund 4000
metern höhe im vorgebirge des himalaya
die maschine der tara er war zur
geburtsstadt langsam unterwegs einem
beliebten touristenziel westlich der
hauptstadt kathmandu
die absturzursache ist noch unklar
hessens ministerpräsident bouffier ist
bei einem großen festakt mit
musikalischen ehren aus dem amt
verabschiedet worden zur feierlichen
serenade im schloss biebrich kamen
zahlreiche politische weggefährten und
freunde des 70-jährigen cdu politikers
der dienstälteste ministerpräsident
deutschlands zieht sich bewusst vor den
landtagswahlen im kommenden jahr zurück
morgen soll zu seinem nachfolger der
amtierende landtagspräsident boris rhein
gewählt werden
im vergangenen jahr hat die polizei in
deutschland deutlich mehr fälle
sexuellen brauchs an kindern erfasst
laut eine sonderauswertung der
polizeilichen kriminalstatistik
verdoppelte sich die zahl der fälle von
missbrauchsdarstellungen auf über
39.000 auch wurden mehr kinder und
jugendliche in deutschland opfer
sexualisierter gewalt mehr als 17.000
700 wk-präsident möglich erklärte das
seien im durchschnitt 49 minderjährige
opfer jeden tag
fast 50 kinder also unglaubliche zahl
die ihnen pro tag in diesem land
sexualisierte gewalt angetan wird es
dunkelfeld ist weiterhin vermutlich groß
nordrhein westfalen mit seinem
innenminister reue hat dem thema in den
letzten jahren priorität eingeräumt will
die täter nicht davonkommen lassen dort
wo polizei und behörden hinschauten
taten sich abgründe auf möchte bergisch
gladbach münster inzwischen spricht man
von missbrauchs komplexen ein weiterer
in wermelskirchen ist nun dazu gekommen
und er springt nach angaben der
ermittler die bisherigen dimensionen
ralph goldmann berichtet
es ist bereits das vierte mal innerhalb
von dreieinhalb jahren dass polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft in nordrhein
westfalen vor die presse treten müssen
um von unfassbaren fällen sexualität
gewalt an kindern zu berichten hier in
diesem wohngebiet in der nähe von köln
hatten sich schon im dezember einen 44
jährigen verheirateten und kinderlosen
man ohne vorstrafen festgenommen sie
fanden bei ihm der auch als babysitter
gearbeitet hat millionen videos und
bilder zwölf kinder soll der schwer
sexuell missbraucht und dabei gefilmt
haben
ein solches ausmaß an
menschenverachtender brutalität
und gefühlloser gleichgültigkeit
gegenüber dem leid von kleinen kindern
in schmerzen ihren schreien und ihrer
offensichtlichen angst ist mir noch
nicht begegnet von so etwas habe ich mir
auch nicht vorstellen können nur noch
nicht einmal zehn prozent der daten sind
ausgewertet doch schon jetzt ist klar
das material liefert hinweise auf
dutzende weitere tatverdächtige und
weitere opfer in 14 bundesländern und
österreich
das verfahren hat sich jetzt nicht nur
um diesen beschuldigen sondern die
auswertung hat auch dazu geführt dass
wir mehr als 70 verfahren eingeleitet
haben und die an andere behörden
abgegeben haben die dann in dortiger
zuständig war kalt weiter vorgehen
insgesamt haben wir jetzt 33 geschädigte
die wir bislang identifizieren und
ermitteln können
33 opfer im alter zwischen einem monat
und 14 jahren fünf säuglinge waren dabei
und acht kleinkinder unter drei immer
wieder werden in nordrhein-westfalen
solche sogenannten missbrauchs komplexe
aufgedeckt den vieles dort in personal
und technik investiert worden
innenminister herbert reul sendet heute
eine klare botschaft an alle täterinnen
und täter
aber nicht nur die täter sind im
internet sondern auch hier auch die
polizei und ich kann einen pädophilen
nur sagen wir kriegen euch
vielleicht nicht heute aber eines tages
stehen wir für euro türen doch oft
stoßen die ermittler auch an ihre
grenzen die bka präsident holger münch
heute in berlin beklagte derzeit dürften
daten nur maximal sieben tage
gespeichert werden münch fordert sechs
monate so könnten viel mehr kinder aus
den fängen ihrer peiniger gerettet
werden wir haben den letzten fünf jahren
alleine im bereich
abbildung von sexuellem missbrauch über
19.000 taten einstellen müssen weil es
der einzige ansatz gewesen wäre ein
täter zu ermitteln und keine daten mehr
vorhanden waren in köln waren sie
zumindest in den aktuellen fällen
schnell genug doch die ermittlungen
stehen noch ganz am anfang es könnten
noch wesentlich mehr werden täter und
opfer
er verliere angesichts der taten
mitunter den glauben an die menschheit
sagte der landesinnenminister heute bei
der pressekonferenz herbert reul ich
später interviewgast im heute-journal
update zum komplex wermelskirchen und
den lehrern aus der ermittlungsarbeit in
nordrhein westfalen
so zum ersten mal seit beginn der
pandemie findet die hannover messe
wieder in präsenz stadt für industrie
und wirtschaftsvertreter gelegenheit
endlich wieder persönlich über die
herausforderung der zucker wurde das
sind mehrere krisen die die wirtschaft
fordert bundeskanzler scholz sagte zur
eröffnung die pandemie und der krieg
nehmen der industriellen transformation
nichts von ihrer dringlichkeit der
wandel zu klimaneutralem wirtschaften
müsse rasch kommen erklärte scholz er
setze auf einen geringeren
ressourcenverbrauch künstliche
intelligenz und wasserstoff messe
partnerland ist diesmal portugal
schwer zu schaffen macht wirtschaft und
verbrauchern die sich deutlich
beschleunigen die inflation auf 7,9
prozent stieg sie jetzt im mai laut
statistischem bundesamt nach 7,4 prozent
noch im april frank bethmann was sagen
die experten wann geht die teuerung
wieder zurück na ja es ist schon noch
immer ordentlich druck dem inflations
kessel so formulierte es verhindern
händler wo man auch hinhört von einer
entwarnung bei den preisen ist kaum die
rede neben der energie werden zudem
jetzt die lebensmittel immer teurer auch
die entlastungs paket der
bundesregierung seien bislang nicht der
große wurf findet man hier temporäre
erleichterung ja möglich wenn wir unter
anderem an den tank rabatt denken
allerdings mahnt beispielsweise
friedrich heinemann vom zaw dieser
absehbaren rückgang der inflation darf
aber nicht als langfristige entspannung
missverstanden werden denn von dem was
wir in europa als erklärtes ziel
ausgegeben haben nämlich eine jährliche
preissteigerung von um die zwei prozent
sind wir ja gegenwärtig sehr sehr weit
entfernt und so stimmt ein weiteres
heute veröffentlichten zahlen paar
nachdenklich die verbraucherpreise
steigen schneller als die löhne die vier
prozent um die die löhne immerhin im
ersten quartal im mittel zulegen konnten
gleichen die teuerung von fast sechs
prozent im gleichen zeitraum nicht aus
unterm strich also ein reallohn und
kaufkraftverlust gute argumente also in
den tarifverhandlungen höhere löhne zu
fordern doch die medaille hat zwei
seiten denn zu
lohnabschlüsse befeuern die inflation
weiter diese dynamik ist als lohn preis
spirale gefürchtet und die gilt es zu
vermeiden um jeden preis vielen dank
nach wird
die deutsche bahn bereitet angesichts
vieler baustellen und steigender
passagier und frachtzahlen die kunden
auf weitere verspätungen und ausfälle
vor schon jetzt werde an so vielen
stellen in der infrastruktur repariert
wie noch nie sagte bahn chef lutz und
kündigte zugleich eine generalsanierung
wichtiger strecken ab 2024 an
bundespräsident steinmeier hat die
deutschen medaillengewinner der
olympischen und paralympischen
winterspiele in peking ausgezeichnet im
rahmen einer feierstunde im schloss
bellevue erhielten 26 athletinnen und 31
athleten das silberne lorbeerblatt die
höchste staatliche anerkennung für
spitzenleistungen im sport steinmeier
hob besonders die umstände der spiele
hervor die im schatten des drohenden
krieges in der ukraine stattgefunden
hätten
so wir haben in europa begonnen und
enden auch dort das war
1988 frankreichs präsident mitterrand
der deutsche bundeskanzler helmut kohl
heben ein television projekt aus der
taufe den deutsch französischen
kulturkanal arte sendet start ist 1992
auf den tag heute vor 30 jahren
inzwischen ist arte längst erwachsen und
es gibt viele grenzgänger zum beispiel
da sagte mir gesicht der arten
nachrichten und das gesicht von heute
journal update
[Musik]
mühsam wollte wie duell mit franco
allemand
6 am programm
der runde geburtstag wird heute abend
natürlich angemessen europäisch gefeiert
simon hrubesch
delos griechische insel voller über
reste antiker hochkultur durch den
klimawandel von überschwemmungen bedroht
symbolträchtiger hätte arte den ort für
die geburtstagsfeier nicht wählen können
aufgeführt werden zahlreiche bekannte
europäische werke unter anderem eine
neufassung von antonio vivaldis herbst
aus den vier jahreszeiten
niemand konnte sich so richtig
vorstellen dass dieses europäische
projekt an der box geschichte wird es
ist eine erfolgsgeschichte geworden ist
es bis heute einzigartig als
multilateraler sender das ausgefallene
es ist bereits seit den anfängen
markenzeichen diesem sender geht es
weder um doktrin noch um zerstreuung er
will weder blind machen noch lang noch
lügen er hat uns nicht zu verkaufen auch
experimentellere zugänge und newcomer
bekommen bei arte eine bühne kuhl soll
einmal zur mitterrand gesagt haben
francois wenn sie nicht aufhören mich zu
ärgern dann zwinge ich sie ein
wochenende lang karte zuschauen
massentauglichkeit ist dabei aber auch
nicht der anspruch des senders tiefe
dafür umso mehr dabei steht arte für
eine eigene bildsprache eine eigene
ästhetik
kreative formate wie carambolage oder
mit offenen karten sind bonbons in der
fernsehlandschaft
arte eine hommage an die kultur und an
europa und arte eine insel der kultur
und verständigung die zum innehalten
einlädt
ja ein bisschen spaß macht auch bisschen
spaß macht auch noch mal herzlichen
glückwunsch und hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit grossem montagskino einen
tarantino film mit starbesetzung
aber nichts für schwache nerven und um
0.45 meldet sich also unsere kollegin
nah sein möchte mir mit unserem
heute-journal update tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend das war gestern schon ein
bisschen kalt für ende mai selbst in
darmstadt das war die höchste temperatur
gestern in deutschland stiegen die
temperaturen nur knapp auf 19 grad auf
dem brocken im harz war die
höchsttemperatur gestern nur fünf grad
hoch und dass uns das so besonders kalt
vorkommt liegt daran dass der mai der ja
morgen zu ende geht eigentlich wieder
mal ein viel zu warmer monat war selbst
im vergleich zu und viele jährige
klimatologische mittel der jahre 1991
bis 2020 und kalt bleibt auch erstmal
denn diese tiefs bringen aus nordwesten
besonders dem norden weiterhin eher
kühle temperatur aber dann mischt sich
dieses tiefe der iberischen halbinsel
ein dann wird es von südwesten wärme
sogar schwül heiß und zum ende der woche
drohen unwetter heute nacht gibt es
letzte regenschauer hier an der ostsee
die ostwärts abziehen dann wird es zum
teil auch klar und das bildet sich nebel
und auch in dieser nacht wird es wieder
sehr kalt in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und auch in der
lüneburger heide sinken die werte auf
drei grad es droht also örtlich
bodenfrost bilder bleibt die nacht an
der ostsee um ganz im westen morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee bei 16 grad
sonst werden 16 bis 21 grad erreicht die
22 bis 25 grad beschränkten sich auf die
donau den mittel und den ural es gibt
morgen häufig freundliches wetter
allerdings entwickeln sich dann zum
nachmittag schauer und gewitter und
ähnlich wechselhaft geht es auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter freitag drohen
unwetter genannt